CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS WILL
COME TO ORDER. A GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC SENATORS
IN THE SENATE STAFF WE MUST
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
AND HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING
AND BY THE WAY I'M GLAD TO SEE
THAT FOLKS ARE AT HEARING THE
SOCIAL DISTANCING. I ALSO SEE
THAT WERE ALL MESSED UP. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATORS OF MY
WIFE ACTUALLY SO THIS IMPROVES
MY LOOKS. THE IN COMPLIANCE
WITH THOSE ORDERS THE CENTER
WILL BE HOLDING. AN ESSENTIAL
HEARING AND IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC. IN OUR
EMPLOYEES. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
WE'LL BE USING TELEPHONE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE
NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT
HERE IN A MOMENT. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT CALL IN NUMBER IS
ONE EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. THREE
THREE SIX FOUR FOUR FOUR ONE.
IN THE ACCESS CODE IS FIVE NINE
ZERO FOUR. THREE FIVE FIVE.
WILL MOVE THE PUBLIC COMMENT A
MODERATOR WILL IDENTIFY YOU
INDIVIDUALLY OPEN YOUR LINE AT
THAT TIME YOU MAY ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. NOTE THAT IN ORDER
FOR US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MUTE. THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY. IN ANY
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
ARE ADJUSTING TO USE FOR THE-
USING NEW ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENCE SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD
OF BEFORE WE GO ANY FURTHER WHY
DON'T WE- GO AHEAD AND HAVE THE
UP. FROMNOTED. SO MR CHESSEN
IF YOU COULD DO THE HONORS. I'M
BURKE HERE NIELSEN IF HERTZBERG
LABOR HERE EARN. WE HAVE HERE.
THANK YOU NAM I THINK
EVERYONE'S- DID EVERYONE HAVE
ON THEIR THEIR MICROPHONE WHEN
THEY ANNOUNCED THAT THEY WERE
HERE SO WE COULD PROPERLY
RECORDED. I THINK SO OKAY I DID
NOT OF I'M HERE AT SEVEN HILLS
AND THANK YOU CENTER NIELSEN.
ALL RIGHT NOW WITHOUT FURTHER
DO WILL BEGIN TODAY'S HEARING
WITH TWO BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. SB ELEVEN SIXTY THREE
BAR VICE CHAIR CENTER NIELSEN.
IN OUR COMMITTEE BILL SB NINE
SEVENTY WHICH IS ON CONSENT OF.
ALL RIGHT LET'S GO AHEAD AND-
LET'S THE- LET'S HEAR FROM OUR
FIRST AND ONLY AUTHOR CENTER
NIELSEN ON YOU MAY PRESENT SB
ELEVEN SIXTY THREE AND IF YOU
CARE TO PRESENT FROM THE DíAS
I THINK THAT'S PERFECTLY FINE
YEAH LET'S DO THAT. AT ALL.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND- BUT
COLLEAGUES ON THE COMMITTEE.
THE CONCERN OF MOTIVATING THE
BILL IS. THE INTERACTION OF
CITIZENS. WITH PEOPLE WHO WOULD
BE MOVING BALLOTS AROUND IT IS
LIMITED TO THE NOVEMBER GENERAL
ELECTION. AND THAT WOULD
HOPEFULLY BE THE DURATION OF
THIS EMERGENCY SITUATION. IT'S
MOTIVATED BY A SIMPLE QUESTION.
DO WE WANT TO HAVE STRANGERS
GOING DOOR TO DOOR. WITH
BALLOTS. THAT ENHANCES THE
EXPOSURE. OF INDIVIDUALS TO
THOSE WHO WOULD BE COMING AND
DOOR TO DOOR. WHO HAVE NO
REQUIREMENTS IMPOSED ON THEM TO
CERTIFY THAT THEY ARE
AUTHORIZED OR CAPABLE OF. DOING
THIS COLLECTION OF BALLOTS. AND
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THEY ARE
EXPOSED TO AS HIS THEIR
HOUSEHOLD. POSSIBILITIES OF
INFECTED INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
COMING IN FACT DOOR TO DOOR
THEY ARE STRANGERS. AND NOT
HAVE TO BE CERTIFIED IN ANY
MANNER OR WAY. TO COLLECT THE
BALLOTS DOOR TO DOOR. THE
STANDARD IMPOSED BY THE
LEGISLATION. IT WOULD BE. THE
NEWER STANDARD. IN THE LATE THE
VALLEY VOTE BYMAIL AND VOTER
WHO CANNOT RETURN THEIR BALLOT
CAN DESIGNATE NOW A SPOUSE
CHILD PARENT A GRANDPARENT.
CONSANGUINITY I THINK IS OF
FAMOUS BORDER THE FANCY WORD
FOR THAT BUT THERE'S A DIRECT
RELATIONSHIP. A CO HABITANT. IS
ALSO. ON THAT LIST. BOB RISE IN.
TO CONVEY THAT BALLOT. PHYSICAL
DISTANCING IS SOMETHING THAT-
IS EVIDENT RIGHT HERE IN THIS
HEARING TODAY AND HOW WE ARE
ALL IN SOCIETY OF BITING. THIS
BILL RETURNS CALIFORNIA TO THE
LONG HAUL L. STANDARD. THAT
WOULD BE ONLY DURING TIMES OF
EMERGENCY. IT WOULD BE HELD.
AND THAT WOULD BE I ARGUE THE
POLL THE FRANCHISE OF THE
VOTERS AND FACILITATE THEM WITH
THE MAXIMUM. OF PROTECTION.
FROM THIS DISEASE THAT WE ARE
NOW SO UNFORTUNATELY CONTENDING
WITH. IT'S VERY SIMPLE AND
AGAIN MISTER CHAIRMAN WITH DISH
AND COLLEAGUES IT IS CONFINED
TO THIS NOVEMBER. THE GENERAL
ELECTION IT WOULD BE A TEST TO
SEE THE EFFICACY BUT I HAVE NO
DOUBT. THE TEN BUT NOT CAN I
THREE ANY ARGUMENT. THAT THIS
WOULD NOT MORE PROTECT OUR
INDIVIDUAL CITIZENS THAT THIS
VERY CRITICAL TIME. BY LIMITING
THE CUP TO PEOPLE ANY PEOPLE.
TO COME TO THEIR DOOR WITH THAT
IN HIS FOR GAYS CERTIFICATION
OF THE HEALTH OR ANYTHING ELSE.
THAT IS A SIMPLE BILL DISCOUNT.
THANK YOU SIR NIELSEN- DUE TO
THE CONSTRAINTS REGARDING
LENGTHY HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND NEW CLEANING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEES WILL
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON ALL
TESTIMONY ACCORDINGLY EACH SIDE
WILL BE LIMITED TO A TOTAL OF
THREE MINUTES ALL THOSE WISHING
TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS THEIR NAME.
AFFILIATION A POSITION ON THE
MEASURE- I UNDERSTAND THAT-
MISS RUTH WEISS WITH THE
ELECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT
CALIFORNIA IS YOUR WITNESS
SENATOR NIELSEN THAT IS
CORRECT- AND IF MISS WEISS IS
ON THE PHONE THIS WOULD BE THE
APPROPRIATE TIME TO PROCEED.
MISS WHITE ON THE PHONE. THANK
YOU TO NEAR YES I CERTAINLY AM
AND I APPRECIATE THE HONOR OF
TALKING WITH YOU TODAY- I AM
THE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
ELECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE SUBMITTED A
PETITION LETTER IN SUPPORT OF
SENATOR NIELSEN BILL. AND BOB
BEFORE I ENTER INTO MY COMMENTS
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW IF YOU HAD
ANY QUESTIONS REGARDING THE
CONTENT OF THAT LETTER. I DON'T
IN WE CAN ASK COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AT THE END OF THE THEN NEW
TESTIMONY IF THEY'VE ANY
QUESTIONS BUT I DON'T. YEAH BE
GREAT OKAY WELL IT'S A LITTLE
WEIRD IT IS SINCE I CAN'T BE
YOUR BUT YOU KNOW WE'RE DOING
THE BEST WE CAN UNDER NDER
VERY DIFFICULT CIRCUMSTANCES.
OUR WHOLE LIVES HAVE BEEN
TURNED UPSIDE DOWN IN FEBRUARY
OR BEGINNING OF MARCH AND WE'RE
CONTINUING. TO CONDUCT
OURSELVES IN A VERY ABNORMAL
WAYS HERE- I'M AND KNOWING THAT
THERE WOULD BE NO CURE OR
VACCINE IN TRYING TO HELP US
OUT WITH THE TWENTY TWENTY
ELECTION CYCLE. ARE GOVERNED.
ON MAY BE AT THE STAFF OF A AN
EXECUTIVE BOARD THAT CHANGED-
THE WAY IN WHICH BALLOTS WILL
BE DISTRIBUTED SO THAT NOW
EVERY. REGISTERED VOTER IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WILL
RECEIVE ABOUT BY MAIL BALLOT IN
THIS IS TO. MAKE SURE NO ONE
GETS A LAST MINUTE DEFEND
FRIDAY IN FRANCHISE SITUATION
DUE TO AN INABILITY LAST MINUTE
OR OR- OF GOING OUT. TO VOTE
REGULARLY I'M I'M GLAD TO SEE
THAT THE GOVERNOR REALIZED THAT
SOME VOTERS ARE GOING TO NEED
ASSISTANCE OR SOME OTHER OF
LAST MINUTE. SO HE HAS.
PROVIDED FOR JUST SET THAT UP A
WELL. BY A- LOT OF THAT THE DOW.
OF WHAT HE IS DOING THE FIRST
VOTERS. IN THE THIRD. TIME
SENATOR NIELSEN BILL ADDRESSES
ONE HEALTH AND SAFETY CONCERNS
THAT IS NOT COVERED. BY THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER ARMED AND THAT
IS THAT- EVEN IF HEART
INFECTION RATES HAVE SUBSIDED
CONSIDERABLY BY OCTOBER WHEN
THE VOTE BY MAIL BALLOTS ARE
SENT OUT. IT IS STILL TRUE THAT
A VERY. ATION BUT ARE MOST AT
RISK NOW OF ILLNESS AND.
UNFORTUNATELY THOUGH THE POP.
THAT ARE ARE THE ONES MOST.
HAVE BALLOT COLLECTORS TO US
THEM. AND I CAN. THE THAT
STATUS QUO AND NINETEEN TWENTY
ONE UNDER THESE CIRCUMSTANCES-
I WILL ECHO WHAT SENATOR NELSON
SAID IS THAT WE SUBJECT THEM.
TO PERSON TO PERSON CORD. YEAH
WHICH IS ANTITHESIS OF WHAT WE
WANT TO GET A PROTECT THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE. ILL OR WHO ARE.
ELDERLY OR IN SOME OTHER WAY
ACCEPTABLE TO THE PARTICULAR
CONTAGION THAT WE'RE ALL
CONCERNED ABOUT RIGHT NOW- WE
ARE VERY CONCERNED THAT THE I.
T. C. H. AND MAKE SURE THAT.
THE ORDER HAS A VOTE AND- VOTE
IN A WAY IN WHICH THAT VOTER
DESIRES- AND WE ARE CONCERNED
THAT NO DISENFRANCHISEMENT
WOULD TAKE PLACE WELL WE'RE A
CALL. THAT UNDER THE- YEAH
CONSIDERATION. SB ELEVEN SIXTY
THREE THAT THAT'S CARE OF FIRST
OF ALL EVERY REGISTERED VOTER
WILL BE MAILED THE FINAL BALLOT
THAT HAS A RETURN ENVELOPE THAT
IS POSTAGE PAID BACK NINETY
NINE POINT 9% ANYONE WISHING
USING BALLOT. PUT IT IN MY ON
THEIR POOR THE OF THEIR DRAW
THE AND THAT SHOULD BE. VERY
EASY PROCESS FOR ANYONE WISHING
TO VOTE. ON AND THEN IN
ADDITION AS SENATOR NELSON OF
POINTED OUT THIS BILL ALSO
STILL ALLOWS THOSE WHO NEED THE
ASSISTANCE AND THE HELP OF
SOMEONE RETURNING ABOUT FOR
THEM. TO BE ABLE TO RELY ON A
FAMILY MEMBER OR A MEMBER OF
THEIR HOUSEHOLD TO DO THAT. IT
DOESN'T APPEAR THAT THERE'S ANY
DOWNSIDE AT ALL CHIU THEIR-
BILL AND YET THERE'S A VERY
IMPORTANT. FIGHT AND IDEAS
CONTINUED PROTECTION ON BOTH TO
OUR MOST VULNERABLE. TO THIS
PANDEMIC BUT WE ARE ALSO
CONCERNED ABOUT NOW SO I WOULD
LIKE TO. THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
THE CAN AGAIN CLICK HERE AND-
ARTS AND- ARE SENATE BILL OF
FIFTY THREE IF THE NECESSARY
HAND MAY TO PROTECT AND SAFETY
OUR MOST CITIZENS I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME WILL BE
HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS IF YOU
HAVE ANY THANK YOU MISS WISE.
ALL I ASK THIS IS AN UNUSUAL
PROCEEDING LET ME ASK A COUPLE
QUESTIONS AND I'LL TURN OVER TO
OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
QUESTIONS- MISS WEISSER ANYONE
ANYONE NEWMAN TESTIFIES LATER
ON IS ANYONE. ANYONE CONTRACTED
THE COVE ADVICE FROM THE MARCH
THREE. ELECTION DURING THAT
ELECTION THE LAW AS IT EXISTS
RIGHT NOW WAS IN FULL FORCE AND
EFFECT AND IF I'M NOT AWARE BUT
MISS WHITE SO YOU AWARE OF
ANYONE THE CONTRACTED COVERT
NINETEEN. CONSEQUENCE OF THE-
ELECTION I THINK THAT WAS.
EARLY ON IN OUR IN OUR TESTING
MEDICAL. THAT WOULD BE VERY
DIFFICULT TO TRACE ANYTHING
BACK WITH ANY RELIABILITY THAT
THAT PARTICULAR MOMENT IN TIME
SO I THINK. IT WOULD BE PRETTY
IMPOSSIBLE YOU KNOW. BUT ABOUT
THAT TIME IS WHEN. THE
EXPLOSION OF THE- I REYES BEGAN
YOU KNOW NATIONWIDE. AND IN
SOME PLACES MORE THAN OTHERS SO
IT IS LOGICAL LOGICAL TO ASSUME
THAT ANY PLACE INCLUDING.
VOTING LOCATIONS WHERE PEOPLE
WERE IN CLOSE PROXIMITY THAT
THERE WAS A GREAT OPPORTUNITY
TO PASS ALONG. SOME SOMETHING
FROM SOMEONE WHO IS ALREADY-
DISEASE. BUT I AND I AM AWARE
OF A VERY SUCCESSFUL BALLOT
HARVESTING IS THE TERM IS
APPLIED. EFFORT TO- IN IN MY
OWN ELECTION WHERE THERE WERE
THOUSANDS OF BALLOTS THAT WERE-
PICKED UP BY OTHERS IN RETURN
DIVERSE FISCAL OPERATION
FISSION OPERATION VERY
EFFECTIVE OPERATION- AND- IS I
UNDERSTAND UNDER THIS BILL THAT
WOULD BE. THAT WOULD BE PER
CLICK IS THAT RIGHT SENATE
TWICE. BY SUCH INDIVIDUALS
OTHER THAN WHAT WE REFERENCE
HERE IN THE BILL. THAT WAS MY
OPPONENT SO AT A I WOULD GUESS
THAT THAT MAY HAVE AN IMPACT ON
THE STOCK SELECTION BUT NAME IN
ALL RIGHT OTHER QUESTIONS BY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. SEC
OKAY CENTER STARTED YOUR
QUESTION. I'D NOT COARSENESS
BRIEF COMMENT ALL RIGHT- JUST
WANT TO APPLAUD THE CONTEXT IN
WHICH WE'RE OPERATING WITH THE
GOVERNOR SWIFT ACTION ON
MAILING OUT THESE BALLOTS AND-
IT WILL BE A TRICK ELECTION TO
GET THROUGH ANYTHING WE'RE
DOING TO. TIM THE LADY A THE
THANKS BYE MADE IT SEEM TO ME
TO BE EMPOWERMENT DEMOCRACY SO
I JUST I WAS GOING TO TRY TO
RUN THAT BILL IF THE GOVERNOR
HADN'T- JUMPED ON IT SOONER
BUT- I LIKE THE MOMENT AND
WE'RE HEADING IN. WHO ARE A
WILL USE A CO AUTHOR OF OUR
BILL SENATOR STERN BECAUSE OF
THAT ALL RIGHT ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU. SO HERTZBERG. BUT WE HAVE
OTHERS ON THE LINE THAT THAT
WISH TO. VOICE THEIR SUPPORT
ARE ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
ROOM- TWENTY FORTY WHO WISH TO
FIND SUPPORT OF US BE A LET.
THE THREE. GOING ONCE TWICE ALL
RIGHT IT SOUNDS LIKE THERE ARE
NO WITNESSES ROOM- FORTY TWO OH
THREE- NEXT- I'M SORRY TWENTY
FORTY- LEVEL. MOVED OUT OF
WITNESSES WAITED TEST FIVE VIA
TELECONFERENCE. SO MODERATOR IF
YOU WOULD BEGIN PLEASE PROP
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN. SIXTY
THREE AND WE WILL BEGIN AND
MODERATOR IF YOU HAVE AN IDEA
OF HOW MANY ARE IN THE QUEUE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT THAT WOULD
BE. HELP US. JOHN IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME THE HERE TOWN
INDICATING PLACING QUEUE NUMBER
WILL GIVE YOU A NUMBER AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE YOU BY YOUR
NUMBER. AGAIN IF YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AS OF RIGHT NOW
IT LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE ABOUT
ELEVEN THAT ARE IN SUPPORT. ALL
RIGHT OUR MODERATOR IF WE COULD
BEGIN THE PROCESS THAT WOULD BE
GREAT. ABSOLUTELY SO FIRST
WE'LL GO TO LINE EIGHTEEN LINE
EIGHTEEN YOU ARE OPEN LET ME
OF. ON ON MY OWN TIME SO TO
SPEAK- SO WE'VE WE'VE ALREADY
EXHAUSTED THE THREE MINUTES
ACTUALLY WELL WELL OVER THREE
MINUTES IN SUPPORT SO THOSE ARE
WE Q. TO. TESTIFY IF YOU GIVE
US YOUR NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION
AND UP SOUMYA SUPPORT SO GO
AHEAD. A LINE EIGHTEEN YOU ARE
OPEN PLEASE MAKE SURE NOT MUTED.
I JUST HANG OPPOSITION
SUBSTANTIVELY. I'M HE SAID HE
SAID OPPOSITION- OPPOSITION TO
OKAY THIRTY EIGHT A LINE THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD- YES MY
NAME IS COLIN BRITAIN I'M WITH-
III PCA AND SOLANO COUNTY AND
WE SUPPORT THE BILL. HE VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. NEXT WE GO TO
LINE THIRTY NINE THIRTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD YEAH MY NAME IS MIKE
MULLIN AND I'M A RESIDENT OF
PHYLLIS THE FOLK ALIEN WITH THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY AND I AM IN
FAVOR OF THE WORK AT THE END
ELECTION INTEGRITY ZONE I'M IN
FAVOR OF THE BILL. THANK YOU.
NEXT YEAR THE LINE THIRTY TO
THIRTY TO YOUR OPEN. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME. HEAR ME HELLO YES
WE CAN HEAR YOU HEAR YOU. OKAY
SORRY HI- MY NAME IS EUNICE
MELANIE I'M IN SOLANO COUNTY I
LIVE IN VALLEJO I'M ALSO A LOT
OF WORK HERE WHICH HE ALEXIAN
INTEGRITY PROJECT. AND I
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU.
NEXT YEAR THE NUMBER FOURTEEN
FOURTEEN YOUR OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS GWEN MYERS
AND I RESIDE IN ROSEVILLE I AM
WITH ELECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT
CALIFORNIA AND I APPROVED A
BILL. THANK YOU. THE NEXT TO GO
TO NUMBER FORTY SIX FORTY SIX
ARE OPEN. CAN YOU HEAR ME OK.
YES HELLO YES WE CAN HEAR YOU
THE OTHER. GREAT THIS IS MIKE
AND MELINDA THOMAS FROM EL
DORADO COUNTY AND VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU.
THE NEXT TO GO TO NUMBER THIRTY
ONE THIRTY ONE YOU ARE OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JILL
WILLOW AND- MY WIFE AND I A
BOMB ARE VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL WE ARE IN SAN LUIS
OBISPO COUNTY AS JUST. REGULAR
CITIZENS. THANK YOU. OUR NEXT
TO GO TO NUMBER TWENTY THREE
TWENTY THREE YOU ARE OPEN. HI
KATIE HEAR ME A YES WE CAN.
OKAY YES HI MY NAME IS CAROLYN
CENTER. ALEXIAN OBSERVER IN-
YOLO COUNTY AND I AM VERY MUCH
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL- I THINK
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE NOT
BASE OUR OPINION ON- HOW IT
AFFECTED YOUR PERSONAL
ELECTION. I THINK OUR CONCERN
IS PROTECTING PEOPLE AND
THERE'S WHO ARE ELDERLY ARE
THAN WHAT THEY'RE MOSTLY TO
COME IN CONTACT WITH HIS HANDS
ON EMERGENCY SUPPORT. OF STILL
CAN'T YOU KIND THANK YOU. THE
NEXT TO GO TO NUMBER NINETEEN
NINETEEN YOUR OPEN. YES THIS IS
CHARRO AND MY WIFE BEING ME WE
ARE FROM ROSEVILLE AND WE'RE
TOTALLY IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE. THANK YOU. NEXT TO A
NUMBER TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FOUR
YOU ARE OPEN. THE NUMBER WE CAN
HEAR YOU. TERRY CURARE EL
DORADO COUNTY AND I'M WITH THE
REPUBLICAN. OKAY MANY IN OUR
COUNTY AND WE ALSO HAVE A VERY
HIGH SENIOR POPULATION SO I
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT NIELSEN
SPELL THANK YOU. THANK YOU. A
NEXT TO A NUMBER FIFTEEN
FIFTEEN YOU ARE OPEN. MY NAME
IS SUZANNE I'M FROM EL DORADO
COUNTY IN I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. A NATIONAL NUMBER
THIRTY THREE THIRTY THREE YOU
ARE OPEN. NEAR ME. YES WE CAN
YEAH MY NAME'S THOMAS AND MY
WIFE IS ALSO A DAWSON. AND
WE'RE WITH THE REPUBLICAN
CENTRAL COMMITTEE IN SAN LUIS
OBISPO COUNTY AND WE'RE IN
FAVOR OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THE NEXT TO GO TO
NUMBER THIRTY FIVE THIRTY FIVE
YOU ARE OPEN. HELLO I AM JOANNE
BOWEN I'M A REGISTERED VOTER IN
YOLO COUNTY AND I AM VERY HAPPY
TO HEAR THAT EVERYONE WILL BE
RECEIVING- SPECIAL ENVELOPE TO
RETURN THEIR BALLOTS WITH EASE.
AND I AM IN FAVOR OF
PROTECTING. INDIVIDUAL VOTERS
AND PEOPLE THAT WANT TO GO DOWN
TO THEIR DOORS TO COLLECT THE
BALLOT AND I OF COURSE SENATOR
NEAL INFILL 11-3 THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE ONE
FINAL IN SUPPORT- WE GOT A LINE
FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. A
FORTY EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN. YEAH
ONE OF THE BACKERS RESIDE.
ACCOUNT EIGHT OUT I. EARLIER
YOU. TAKE CARE OF THE HIGHER
RISK BUT ALMOST BALD POPULATION
OUR COMMUNITY I THINK THAT WE
NEED TO AVOID THIS PRACTICE
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THAT ALL OF
THE POSTAGE PREPAID THERE IS NO
REASON TO EXPOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE
VULNERABLE AND I URGE YOU TO-
SUPPORT. THIS BILL ON BALLOT
HARVESTING FOR THE FALL
ELECTION. PARTY THANK YOU OF
MISTER MODERATOR THE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
AT THE TIME THERE ARE NO
FURTHER IN SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT
NOW NOW WE'LL TURN TO THOSE WHO
OPPOSE IN THE SAME RULES APPLY
TO THOSE WHO ARE OPPOSED AS
WHAT IT IS APPLIED TO THOSE WHO
SUPPORTED. SO THE INITIAL
WITNESS WILL BE GIVEN- AS MUCH
AS THREE MINUTES AND THEN
OTHERS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. THE JUST STATE
THEIR NAME IN THE ORGANIZATION
AFFILIATION THANK YOU OF ALL
RIGHT. BUT I DON'T. YOUR ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE WHO IS
OPPOSED IF THEY ARE IF THEY
COME FORWARD I DON'T SEE
ANYONE. ALRIGHT IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY A SEEING THE FOLKS ARE
SHAKING THEIR HEAD THE NEGATIVE
SO SOON IS ONLY TWENTY FORTY.
BOB HOW ABOUT FOLKS ON THE
PHONE. HONEST MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE INDIVIDUALS ON THE PHONE
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION- TO THE BILL. TO SB
ELEVEN SIXTY THREE AND ON THE
PHONE AND IF YOU ARE NOW IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AGAIN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AT THIS TIME IT
LOOKS LIKE- WE HAVE FOR THAT
ARE IN OPPOSITION SO FIRST
WE'LL GO TO LINE EIGHTEEN LINE
EIGHTEEN YOU ARE OPEN. CAPTION
AND BY NAME IS ERNICE
CONTRACTOR AND I LOOK AT THE
TRAINING WITH THE AMERICAN
CIVIL LIBERTIES UNION OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. SB ELEVEN
SIXTY THREE WOULD CREATE
UNNECESSARY AN ARBITRARY LIMIT
ON. WHO MADE SUCH A BURGER AND
HELPING THE RETURN OF THE UP
AND NOW BALLOT. CALIFORNIA
ELECTION LAW ALREADY PROVIDE
SIGNIFICANT PROTECTION OF THE
PROCESS BY WHICH A DESIGNATED
INDIVIDUAL MAY RETURN ANOTHER
PERSON'S BALLOT. EXISTING LAW
CONTAINS NUMEROUS RESEARCH AND-
THAT ARE ALREADY ACTING
ELECTION TO CARE. ALSO
CALIFORNIA TO FLEX THAT THEY
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
BALLOT COUNT. IN DETAIL. THE
KINDS OF CONSTRAINTS ON YOUR
MARRIAGE OF THE MALE COLLEGE SB
ELEVEN SIXTY THREE AT NOW
SEEKING REINSTALL. EVEN THOUGH
HAS NOT A PROBLEMS THE EXTENT
OF THE GALLAGHER. THIRD PARTY
CALLER. RESTRICTION MUST BE A
LOT AND THREE ARE JUST THE
OFFICER THERE FUNDAMENTALLY.
ELEVEN SIXTY THREE WOULD
PROHIBIT EXTENDED FAMILY
MEMBERS LIVING NEAR VOTER SUCH
AS UNCLE AND OR TELEPHONE FROM
RETURNING YOUR LOVED ONES
BALLOT. BETTER TO LET ALONE AND
HAVE NO IMMEDIATE FAMILY
MEMBERS NEARBY WOULD BE BANNED
FROM ENTRUSTING KIND NEIGHBOR
pOR FRIEND TO HELP THEM RETURN
THEIR BALLOT. SB ELEVEN SIXTY.
HAVE A PARTICULARLY DETRIMENTAL
IMPACT ON VOTING PARTICIPATION
FOR SOME PEOPLE DISABILITIES.
INCLUDING THOSE WITH MOBILITY
DISABILITIES WHO HAVE A
DIFFICULT TIME LEAVING THEIR
HOMES AND GETTING TO POLLING
LOCATIONS. VOTERS YOU CURRENTLY
AVAIL THEMSELVES. DUE TO LAST
MINUTE EMERGENCIES THE VOTER OR
A CLOSE FAMILY MEMBER FALLS ILL
OR GETS INJURED THE VOTERS CAR
BREAK DOWN ON PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION IS UNAVAILABLE
FOR THE BETTERMENT OF WEIGHT
BECAUSE I'M NOT FASTER SUCH AN
ESCALATING WILD FAR. ELEVEN
SIXTY THREE WITH ARBITRARILY
RESTRICTS TO VOTER ME ALL.
RETURNING A BALLOT SPECIFICALLY
AT A TIME WHEN MANY VOTERS WILL
NEED FLEXIBILITY THE MOST
DURING A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY. HE THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS WILL BE SHELTERING
AT HOME NOVEMBER BECAUSE
THEY'RE VULNERABLE TO CO THAT
NINETEEN OR BECAUSE THEY'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT INFECTION AS
YOU ARE. PEOPLE WITH CONCORD
SYSTEMS WILL BE UNABLE TO
RETURN ABOUT THEMSELVES BY
DROPPING THE MARKS ON ELECTION
DAY. THE LETTER SHOULD NOT BE
FORCE. HOW AND THE RIGHT TO
VOTE. THREE RESPECTFULLY ASK
ABOUT THANK YOU. THANK YOU- IN
JUST AS WE- PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY THIS MISS WEISS
QUESTIONS OF PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR FOLKS TO S.
THE- OPPONENT OF THE BILL
ANYONE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
SEEING NOT ALL RIGHT MISTER
MODERATOR- I THINK THERE ARE
THREE OTHERS IS THAT CORRECT
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. THAT IS CORRECT
RIGHT IF THE NEXT CONTINUE TO
KEEP THE LINES OPEN AND ALLOW
THEM TO TESTIFY. NEXT YEAR LINE
FORTY ONE FORTY ONE GO HEAD.
JUSTIN ROUTE ON BEHALF OF THE
RISING IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANKS TO A NUMBER
FORTY TWO FORTY TWO YOUR OPEN.
HM ONE BY THE HAVE A SECRETARY
THEY ARE LIKE FOR THE- IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AND LASTLY- WE GO TO LOU NUMBER
THIRTY SIX THIRTY SIX YOU ARE
OPEN. THE STORE ROSE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA- WE
ARE VERY MUCH IN OFFICE THIS
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH. PARTY
THANK YOU ANY OTHERS MISTER
MODERATOR TESTIFYING IN
OPPOSITION. AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO FURTHER IN THE QUEUE
ALL RIGHT- LET ME TURN ONCE
AGAIN TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS EE
IF THERE'S ANY OTHER COMMENTS
QUESTIONS NONE ALL RIGHT-
CENTER NIELSEN YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS BUT I ASKED YOU TO THE
AND THE OF THE TIMES THAT WE'RE
NOW DEALING WITH. EVEN IN THIS
ROOM TODAY. WITH NOBODY PRESENT
OTHER THAN JUST THE PRINCIPLES
HERE ON STAFF. WE'RE WEARING
MASKS ALL OVER WE WEARING MASKS
NOW. I CONSIDERED AN AMENDMENT
TO THE BILL IT WOULD SUGGEST
THAT WE- CUT REQUIRE THOSE WHO
CAME DOOR TO DOOR. TO COLLECT
BALLOTS WOULD HAVE A MASK AT
LEAST. THEY DON'T HAVE TO SPUR
CERTIFIED ANYWAY SO YOU NEVER
KNOW WHO IS COLLECTING YOUR
BALLOT. OR WHERE IT'S GOING. TO
WHERE IT WILL BE DEPOSITED. AND
THEY ARE NOT INFORMED AS TO
WHAT CAN HAPPEN IF THE THEY
HAVE CAUSE TO BELIEVE THAT
THERE BALLOT HAS BEEN
IMPROPERLY PLACED. EVEN LOST.
THIS IS BUILT UPON A
UNIMPEACHABLE LOGIC THESE ARE
TRYING TIMES THE VIRULENCE OF
THIS PARTICULAR MALADIES THIS
VIRUS. HAS IN A VERY SHORT TIME.
AFFECTED THE ENTIRE WORLD. AND
WE AS CITIZENS. OUR CAREFULLY
SO QUESTIONING OURSELVES IN THE
SANCTITY OF OUR HOMES OUR
BUSINESSES. WE'RE WEARING MASKS
WASH YOUR HANDS TAKING BALK
STERILIZING ALL KINDS OF
PRECAUTIONS. CURRENT PRACTICE
REQUIRES NO SUCH RIGOROUS
PROTECTION THE CITIZENS.
NEIGHBORS ANYONE. AND THEREFORE
I ARGUE. NOT ONLY FROM THE
SANCTITY OF THE BALLOT ITSELF.
BUT FOR THE HEALTH AND WELFARE
OF MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS.
WHO WILL VOTE. THAT THEY BE
AFFORDED THIS ASSURANCE. THAT
THEY WILL BE PROTECTED. AND
THAT'S WHY I ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
THANK YOU CENTER NIELSEN IS
THERE A MOTION. I THE- BUZZER
NIELSEN IT'S A NEW CIVIC
MICROPHONE THERE I WILL MOVE
THAT ARE NIELSEN MOVES THE
BILL. ALL RIGHT- MISTER
SECRETARY IF YOU WOULD CALL THE
ROLL. YOU'RE GET A SERVICE
CENTER THE CARD IS OUT OF YOU
CAN MAKE YOUR OWN MOTION BOBBLE
WAS OCCURRED SHE SHOULD UP. ALL
RIGHT THIS IS THE CLARITY OF
THE RECORD. THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE THAT ALL OF. RIGHT
MISTER SECTOR IF CALL THE- AND
IS TO PASS TO SENATOR PER.
COMMITTEE NUMBER NOW. NIELSEN
HERTZBERG. IF LEYVA NO LEYVA NO
STERN NOW NO. CODE LIVE- THE BY
THE BILL FAILS OF WE NEXT HAVE
THE CONSENT CALENDAR A MISTER.
HAVE SOME TIME BEFORE THE
ELECTION MAY COME TO BEAR THERE
MAY BE CIRCUMSTANCES THAT ARISE
IT MADE MAKE THIS WORTHY OF
FURTHER CONSIDERATION MAC
REQUEST THIS IS A COURTESY
RECONSIDERATION SURE SENATE
NIELSEN AND YOUR CIRCUMSTANCES
CHANGE AND GOVERNOR MAY. OF
DECIDE THAT THERE ARE OTHER
MEASURES NEED TO BE PUT INTO-
INTO PLACE IN ORDER. THE DARK
ONE PARTY WHICH IS THE HEALTH
AND WELFARE OF CALIFORNIA'S
PROTECTED THANK YOU MISS OUR
FAMILY MEMBERS THANK YOU BOB.
THE NEXT IS THE ACCOUNT. IS OUR
MOTION. SOME OF MOVE BY SENATOR
NIELSEN THIS WAS A CENTER
NIELSEN ALSO HERTZBERG CENTERS
AGAIN YOUR TO CENTERS WORKS TO
FOR TO- MOVE IT'S BURKE. MS
SECTOR IF YOU'D CALL. ON THE
CONSENT. NUMBER FIVE. NIELSEN I
WILSON I HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
AYE LEYVA HI LISA HI STERN
RIGHT TURN ON BOTH ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
TO SENATORS VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PATIENCE ALL SHOULD BE DONE ALL
OF THEM ARE HERE IN PERSON-
THANK YOU FOR THOSE. THE MORE
YOU DO IF YOU WERE NOT A TO
TODAY POLICE YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON ELECTIONS A
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE. YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
POOR. INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN
THE OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS
THANK YOU AND WE APPRECIATE
YOUR PARTICIPATION. ONCE AGAIN
THANK. THE HE IS ADJOURNED.